bonsoir la sécurité sociale il ya
quelques mois on parlait de grandes
réformes
on imaginait alors une très grave
maladie dont on a du mal à se remettre
on pensait au traitement de choc et même
peut-être la chirurgie aujourd'hui on
découvre que le système sécurité sociale
peut être au moins provisoirement
soigner avec des cataplasmes et des
potions même si le pic et s'ils ont un
goût amer quelquefois en quittant le
conseil des ministres ce matin monsieur
vraiment bas ne pouvait pas dire mieux
que ce qu'il a dit je constate at il dit
que tous les français sont attachés à la
sécurité sociale et qu'il faut par
conséquent la sauvegarde et ensuite je
constate que si l'évolution de la
sécurité sociale continue sur sa lancée
cette institution ne pourra plus assumer
le rôle qu'elle a dans le pays sur le
plan social ce propos de peron d'une
logique indiscutable
rejoignez ce plus solennel du président
de la république quelques heures plus
tôt
la tâche du gouvernement est de défendre
le système français de sécurité sociale
contre les désordres qu'un déséquilibre
financier durable lui ferait courir
souvenez-vous il ya quelques mois nous
évoquions sur la foi des prévisions
officielles le gouffre insondable du
budget de la sécurité sociale avec un
déficit prévu pour 77 de 12 à 16
milliards
la tragédie en quelque sorte et
aujourd'hui on constate que au moins
pour cette année le déficit n'atteindra
même pas le demi milliard
le trou est devenu plus acceptable
faut-il en conclure que les prévisions
étaient trop pessimistes et qu'elle se
devait de l'être par précaution pour
l'avenir ou faut-il penser que les
efforts entrepris depuis 16 mois ont
déjà porté leurs fruits a été
successivement l'augmentation des
cotisations 1 % la réduction de la tva
sur les médicaments certaines économies
de gestion mais aussi certaines
économies sur les personnels
paramédicaux qui sont moins bien reçu
mais ça ne suffit pas encore on pense
déjà au déficit de 78 et madame simone
veil qui a depuis le changement de
gouvernement le budget de la sécurité
sociale dans ses attributions a présenté
aujourd'hui les moyens de réduire encore
le déficit sans porter atteinte à la
qualité des soins
françois go
d'abord une confirmation pour trouver de
nouvelles ressources
c'est le gouvernement qu'ils affirment
il n'y aura pas de déplafonnement il n'y
aura pas d'augmentation des cotisations
il n'y aura pas de restriction sur les
prestations en somme on va réaliser des
économies en douceur des économies
autour de deux axes une meilleure
maîtrise des dépenses pharmaceutiques et
une amélioration de la gestion des
hôpitaux le tout en faisant appel à une
responsabilité accrue et des médecins et
des assurés et de la sécurité sociale on
ne peut chaque année augmenter les
cotisations les français interrogés sur
ce point récemment ont estimé que dans
leur antre à une large majorité qui
débourse est assez pour leur santé il
faut donc que cette masse qui est
consacré aux dépenses de santé soit
utiliser au mieux qu'elles soient le
mieux géré possible et que chacun ait
conscience que la santé a un prix et
qu'il ne faut pas en définitive mal usé
de ce que la collectivité met à notre
service pour améliorer notre situation
pour une meilleure gestion des hôpitaux
le ticket modérateur hospitalier va être
remplacé par un forfait à la journée
schématiquement l'assuré paiera entre 15
et 20 francs par jour au lieu de payer
par exemple 20% de la facture de
l'hôpital
on va mettre aussi à l'étude la prise en
charge de certains risques exceptionnels
comme les accidents d'automobile soit
par des assurances privées soit par des
cotisations spécifique versée à
l'assurance maladie
chaque année les accidents de la route
coûtent 1 milliard de francs la sécurité
sociale les salariés de plus de 65 ans
ceux qui travaillent bénéficie
actuellement d'un taux de cotisation
inférieur au taux normal désormais leurs
cotisations seront alignés elles
passeront par conséquent de 2 à 3% pour
la même raison les cotisations des
salariés agricoles seront majorés d'un
an et demi pour cent mise à l'étude
également d'une réforme du ticket
modérateur pour les médicaments le
remboursement de 700 d'entre eux qui ne
sont pas jugés indispensables serait
limité amélioration du contrôle médical
limitation d'absentéisme et puis c'est
appréciable amélioration des soins
dentaires à partir du 1er janvier
178 la prise en charge sera renforcée ce
live temps et c'est une question
importante
comment le déficit estimé à 15 milliards
de francs en septembre dernier at il pu
se réduire d'un coup à 400 millions de
francs en mars 1970 les déficits était
approximatif on l'avait situer entre 13
et 16 milliards en effet les dépenses de
sécurité sociale sur monte à près de 300
milliards et il est donc pas toujours
aisé de faire une estimation tout à fait
précise un point sur les salaires
constituent un milliard de différence et
puis je dois dire j'évoquais les coatis
l'augmentation des cotisations qu'il y a
eu 10 milliards va loin de recettes
nouvelles du fait d'augmentations de
cotisation au dodo lé par conséquent des
actions à long terme bon que les
dépenses de santé des français reste
compatible avec l'évolution des
ressources de la sécurité sociale car si
pour 1977 le déficit de ne pas dépasser
400 millions de francs de france
actuelle est bien pour les années
suivantes
rien n'est encore joué loin de là